ふふふ
いらっしゃいませ
まさきさん 卒業 おめでとうございます
では プレイヤーの方 こちらへどうぞ
卒業 おめでとうございます
というわけで 今回は まさきさんの 卒業を祝いまして
100万円企画 第4弾
つかみ取れ 夢の 100万円
まさき君は ここ6年間
はじめしゃちょー の お手伝いを 非常に 頑張っていただいたということで
卒業記念プレゼント ということで
100万円 を
プレゼント したいと 思います
と言いたいところなんですけどもぉ
こちらに
ルーレットがございます ただ100万円を
まさきさんに 渡すのではなく
100万円の 使い道を このルーレットで 勝手に
決めさせて いただきたいと 思います
こちらのルーレット 0が2つ 1から36の 数字が
あります これ回してもらって
球がころころって なった
数字が 当たりの数字に なるんですけども 数字によって
使い道が決まります まず0か00を
出した瞬間 現金100万円 プレゼントでございます
ほほ すげぇ
車が欲しいと おっしゃっていましたね
車代で 100万円 プレゼントでございます
先生になると いう事で 図書カード 100万円分 プレゼントでございます
なんと
焼肉100万円分
あぁ すごい
みんなで みんなで あぁみんなで
すごい パソコン 100万円
パソコンが欲しいと 言っていたので 100万円分で
パソコンを買ってください
こちら
メトロノーム 100万円分でございます
メトロノームをぜひこれで
買っていただきたいなと 親に育てられましたよね
親に使う 100万円
親孝行をしてもらいたいという
意味を込めて
人の金で 親孝行
没収 現金 以外から 1つ好きなのを 選んでください
要するに この中から 好きなのを 選ぶっていうのが あります
というわけで最後は 没収です
34 35 36 が出てしまうと
没収に
なってしまいます
割とマジで こういうの 引き当てる力すげぇからなぁ
マジで没収 するからね
出ないっしょ 出ないっす 出ないっしょ
よっぽどの 事がないと出ないし 逆に100万円が出れば
もう 何に使ってもらっても構わない
もう (ピー) に行ってもらっても構わない
言ってるみたいになるじゃん 俺が
心の準備は よろしいでしょうか
ちなみに まさきさん 狙いは
狙いはね 好感度を考えると 親に使う100万円かな
好感度を抜きにすると 好感度を抜きにすると現金100万円
いやまじ一発勝負だからねこれ 心の準備はよろしいでしょうか
ルーレット スタート
うわ 怖い
止まる止まる
引いてんじゃん
はい 36番 という事で
没収です
マジで 没収じゃん
OK
もう 嫌だ
よし止めます ねぇ 止めますじゃないよ